we're asked to compute 4,800 or 4,800
divided by eighty and then they want us
to check our answer or they say check
your answer so I'll first do it just a
traditional long division way and then
we'll think about if there's maybe a
faster way to do this or if we can even
do it in our heads so let's just do it
the traditional way first so we have 80
and we want to divide it in two we want
to divide it into 4,800 into 4,800 4,800
or if we want to know the terminology 80
is the devised or 4,800 is the dividend
and the number that we get the number of
times 80 goes into 4,800 that will be we
could call that the quotient I always
get confused and when I start using
words like that so we just think of it
as 80s being divided into 4,800 now the
first thing we say well just 80 go into
4 no does 80 go into 48 no it's bigger
than 48 does 80 go into 480 well that
looks interesting let's see 6 times 8 is
48 so 6 times 80 is 480 we could do that
right here 80 times 6 6 times 0 is 0 6
times 8 is 48 or another way you could
have thought about it is 6 times 8 is 48
and we have this extra 0 here so you add
the 0 right there so 80 goes into 480
six times six times because we're only
considering the 4480 we put the six
right in in 480 s one spot which is
really the tens place but if you just
think about the 480 it's right above the
0 now 6 times 80 is we already saw 480
480 and then we can subtract and we get
zero and we bring down another zero 80
goes into zero how many times what goes
into it zero times zero times 80 is zero
you subtract you get zeros and there's
nothing left to bring down so we're done
4,800 divided by 80 is 60 when the
dividend is four thousand eight
the devise or let me write these words
down this is devised or devised or this
is dividend dividend then our quotient
our quotient is 60 now they want us to
check our answer so we just have to
confirm that 60 times 80 is 4,800 so
let's do that 60 times 80 now there's
two ways you could do it you could just
literally say 6 times 8 is 48 and then
it'll have two zeros here 1 2 that's
4,800 or we can do it by hand 0 times 0
is 0 0 times 6 is 0 then we'll put a 0
here because we're now in the tens spot
put the 0 here 8 times 0 is 0 8 times 6
is 48 add all of this up you get 4,800
so it works a faster way would have just
have been to say 8 times 6 is 48 and you
have 1 2 zeroes here so 1 2 zeroes right
there
now a quick way to thought about 4,800
divided by 80 is to divide both of these
numbers by 10 first and just to think
about it this way what we're doing this
could be written as 4,800 over 80 or
this could be written as let me write it
down here 4,800 over 80 could be written
as 480 times 10 over 8 times 10 over 8
times 10 4,800 is just 480 times 10 and
80 is just 8 times 10 now what happens
here we could view this as being equal
to 480 over 8 over 8 times times this 10
up here divided by this 10
now what's ten divided by ten what's
anything any nonzero number divided by
itself well this is just going to be one
10 goes into 10 one time so we're just
left with 400
eighty over eight so essentially you can
just knock off if you knock you can
knock off the same number of zeros off
of the devise or as the dividend so we
knock off 1 0 here 1 0 there it becomes
480 divided by 8 and that's an easier
problem 8 goes into 480 and you could
say 8 goes into it doesn't go into 4 so
it goes into 48 6 times 6 times 8 is 48
you have no remainder bring down this 0
8 goes into 0 0 times 0 times 8 is 0 no
remainder now we get 60 again so either
way would have worked this ways a little
bit faster you might be able to do in
your head but no matter which way you do
it you get 60 years our answer and we
confirm that it really works